[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar hepiniz hoş geldiniz
ismim Şennur Demir
Ben bir sporcuyum buraya sporcu olarak
katıldım hepimizin hayatında bir oyun
vardır
Yalnız bu oyunun kurallarını kendimiz
belirlememiz gerekir Bununla nasıl
belirleyebiliriz kendimizi geliştirerek
yeniliklere açık olarak İşte benim
oyunumda
tam 25 yaşında başladı
ben 25 yaşıma kadar hiçbir şekilde
sporla alakam yoktu
tek amacımız hedefimiz
olduğumuz yerde doğduğumuz yerde
gördüklerimizi bildiklerimizi yani Bir
dar alanda
yapabildiklerimizi hayatımıza
yansıtabilmekti
İşte benim de hayalim
yaşadığım yerdeki
büyüklerimi arkadaşlarımı örnek alarak
İstanbul'a gelip İstanbul'da bir iş bu
burada çalışmaktı
Nitekim ben de öyle yaptım
lise bittikten sonra hiç üniversite
sınavına falan girmedim zaten bir
dediğim gibi bir hayalim yoktu Bir
hedefim yoktu
İstanbul'a geldim İstanbul'da
tekstilde çalışmaya başladım
ardından güvenlik görevlisi olarak
İstanbul Üniversitesi'nde çalışmaya
başladım
İstanbul'da Artık sıkılmaya başlamıştım
Memleketimi özlüyordum Ben de
bartınlıyım bu arada
Bartın'da Kredi Yurtlar kurumunda özel
güvenlik alımı ilanı gördüm ve Oraya
başvurdum Böylelikle memleketime 2005
yılında geri döndüm
Memleketim ve 2005 yılında geri
döndükten sonra 2007 yılında benim
hayatımın oyunu başladı bu oyun
boks
ve Ben boksa başladım
boksa başlamamda şöyle oldu
Uzakdoğu sporlarına gittiğim bir salonda
bir arkadaşımla tanıştım Bu arkadaşım
boks yaparsam bana neler katacağını Yani
benim yapımın boks sporuna uygun
olduğunu Eğer başarılı olursam
üniversitede okuyabileceğimi
üniversitede okuduktan sonra
dünya ve Avrupa'da derece yaparsam
öğretmen olarak atanabileceğimi
ve bunların yanında güzel parlak bir
Kariyerim olabileceğini anlattı ve ben
de gerçekten Bunları duyduktan sonra çok
mutlu oldum ve bir hedef belirledi
kendimize İşte benim asıl oyunun
kuralları burada başlamış oldum
Ben 2011 yılında Milli sporcu oldum ve
bu milli sporcunun verdiği avantajla
birlikte Bartın Üniversitesi'nde öğrenci
olarak başladım
ve aynı zamanda Kredi yurtlarda da
güvenlik görevlisi olarak çalışıyorum
hem antrenman yapıyorum Hem okuyorum
üçünü bir arada götürmeye çalışıyorum
ben risk aldım dedim ki işimi bırakayım
spordan devam edeyim hedeflerim var ve
ben spora devam ettim
Maalesef her şey benim istediğim gibi ya
da planladığım gibi gitmedi
2013 yılında Ben
dizimden sakatlandım ön çapraz Bağları
kopardım
ameliyat oldum 1 yıl spor ara verdim
ardından geri döndüm çok kısa bir sürede
aynı dizinden tekrar sakatlandım ön
çapraz bağlarımı tekrar kopardım
ve her şey böyle artık benim için
umutsuzluğa Gidiyordu yani planın
dışında taşmıştı hedeflerinden şaşmaya
başlamıştım ve çevremdeki herkeste
diyordu ki; Sen zaten bu spora 25
yaşında başladın
altyapı yok gerçekten haklar Yani bir
spora başlamak için biraz altyapı olması
lazım güçlenmem lazım benim
kaslarımın bu konuda bana azizliği oldu
yani bana diyordu ki artık Dur
ben bu konuda
çevremden çok destek aldım ama
bana bırak diyenler de çok oldu
Yani birinci ameliyattan sonra ikinci
ameliyatı oldum
bırakmak için bir sebep daha olmuştu
bana işte ben ben bu anda aklıma
şu cümle geldi
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Evet cümleyi hatırladım
ilk engelde pes edenler başarı nedir
asla bilmeyecekler bu cümle beni çok
etkilemişti gerçekten ben bu engellerde
pes etmeyecektim ve yoluma kaldığı
yerden devam edecektim ve böyle de yap
bir bakıma yapmaya başladım antrenörlük
yapmaya başladım Bartın'da boks antrenör
oldum İzmir Çeşme'de Türkiye
Şampiyonası'nda çocuklara götürdüm
antrenman olarak dedim ki buraya kadar
gelmişken bari ben de yarışayım
Bir bakalım durumumuza
yarıştım orada 1 maça aldım 2 maçı aldım
üçüncü maça aldım Her şey gayet iyi
ardından orada yarı final maçında el baş
parmağımı kırdım
el baş parmağımı kırdım ersinden maçım
var sabaha kadar buz yaptım ertesi günü
final maçına
eldivene elim zor girdi ve o şekilde ben
maça çıktım ve O maçı da aldım 2016
yılında Ben Türkiye şampiyonu oldum 2-3
yıl sakatlıktan sonra
[Alkış]
ve şampiyondan sonra tekrar parmağımdan
ameliyat olmam gerekiyordu ameliyat
oldum ameliyat bittikten sonra işte
şöyle bir ayet vardı Biz insanların
kaderini kendi çabasına bağlı kıldık
yani bırakayım mı devam edeyim mi
bırakırsam
kabullenmiş olacağım ben dedim ki bu
benim kaderim değil ben çabalamam lazım
sabretmem lazım çalışmam lazım
İyileştikten sonra milli takım kampına
katıldım Milli takım kampında da
seçmeler falan yapıldı seçmeleri
kazandım ve Kazakistan'a dünya
şampiyonasına gittik ve sakatlıklardan
sonra ilk uluslararası dünya şampiyonu
Hamdi benim ve ben bu dünya
şampiyonasında dünya üçüncüsü oldum
ardından dünya şampiyonasından geldik
dünya bir sonraki dünya şampiyonasında
Hindistan'da dünya ikincisi oldum yani
başarılar sakatlıklardan sonra peş peşe
gelmeye başladım işte yani benim artık
mutlu bir oyun olmaya başlamıştı
hayatımda Ben bu konuda çok mutluydum ve
her şey istediğim gibi gidiyordu
daha sonra
[Müzik]
O yüzden ben ameliyatımı erteledim
dünya şampiyonasına geleceğimi söyledim
kulübün Fenerbahçe Spor Kulübü kulübümde
bu konuda destek çıktı Yani ilk önce
sağlığın Evet sağlığım olduğunu
söylediler Ben de ben bütün riski
alıyorum ve dünya şampiyonasında
yarışmak istediğimi söyledim Ve nitekim
yarıştım
1 2 3 maç çok güzel geçti
dizinde çok büyük bir ağrı vardı yarı
finalimi kazandıktan sonra
akşam otele geldiğimde kendime şöyle bir
söz söyledim
buraya kadar geldiysen buradan Geri
dönmenin ne anlamı var yani niye Buraya
kadar geldim Madem Buradan geri
dönecektin ve ben o kendi kendime motive
ederek ertesi günü final maçıma çıktım
ve 40 yaşında dünya şampiyonu oldum
ve
İsterseniz bu anı hep beraber bir kez
daha yaşayabiliriz
[Müzik]
Şennur Demir en büyük isteğim dünya
şampiyonluğu diyordu
[Müzik]
Rekor Kırıyor Türkiye Tarihi yazıyor
Türkiye Tarihi yazıyor Şennur demir
altın madalya alıyor
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
inandığınız şeylerden asla vazgeçmeyin
Yaşınız kaç olursa olsun Bakın ben 25
yaşında başladım spora 25 yaşıma kadar
hiçbir spor hayatım yoktu Aklımda hiçbir
spor yoktu ve böyle bir spor oldun zaten
bilmiyordum Ben Bartın'ın küçük bir
köyünde doğmuşum şehir merkezinde uzağım
ve yönlendiren falan hiç kimse yok ben
25 yaşıma gelmişim karşıma bir kişi
çıkmış Ve böyle bir spor olduğunu böyle
bir oyun olduğunu Bana göstermiş ve
benim
hayatımı değiştirmiş benim hayatım u
şeklinde döndü Ben hayatımda hepsine
benzetirim
Benjamin batının Tuhaf Hikayesi diye bir
film vardı güzel bir filmdi Ben hayatımı
hep ona benzettim Yani benim hayatım
Gerçekten o şekilde döndü ve ben bu spor
sayesinde kendi oyunumun kurallarına
kendim koydum
Kendimi geliştirdim
Üniversiteyi bitirdin yüksek lisans
yaptım aynı zamanda beden eğitimi
öğretmeni olarak atandım şu anda
Fenerbahçe spor kulübünde boks
antrenörüyüm Aynı zamanda da devlet
sporcusuyum Yani bu gurur Hem bana hem
aileme hem arkadaşlarıma fazlasıyla
yeteceğini düşünüyorum inanmaktan
vazgeçmeyin Çok teşekkür ediyorum Çok
sağ olun
[Alkış]